[Musica]
[Applauso]
vi siete mai chiesti cosa sarebbe
successo Se Olivetti avesse vinto la
battaglia per la creazione del primo
personal computer
oggi
avremmo Olivetti Store
oggi avremo Olivetti Store in tutto il
mondo la sede della Silicon Valley
sarebbe ad Ivrea in Italia e
o ped o phone e ubook la farebbero da
padrone
[Applauso]
vi sembra possibile
vi sento
Ma figurati se un italiano può diventare
leader in questo settore
nel
nilamstrong e Buzz aldrin effettuarono i
primi passi sul suolo lunare anche
grazie alla p101 di Olivetti il primo
calcolatore elettronico da scrivania
nella storia
pensate che nel 1965 la NASA acquistò
più di 40 più 101 per il calcolo delle
orbite lunari
in quel periodo Steve Jobs e Bill Gates
erano ancora dei bambini
vedete l'innovazione e la creatività
italiana come elemento chiave per il
successo della missione Apollo 11
Noi italiani siamo un popolo di creativi
di inventori di progettisti siamo
viviamo immersi nella cultura nella
bellezza nell'arte e non ci stanchiamo
di meravigliarci per meravigliare
pensate a come sarebbe il mondo senza le
invenzioni degli italiani senza le
invenzioni di Leonardo
senza la pila di volta senza il motore a
scoppio senza l'elicottero senza la moka
senza la plastica inventata da Natta
senza il microprocessore senza il
touchpad senza il touch screen
inventati da uno scienziato
contemporaneo italiano Federico Faggin
pensate come potremmo utilizzare i
nostri smartphone senza il touch screen
Ma come mai ogni anno i nostri migliori
Talenti
lasciano l'Italia per realizzare i
propri sogni e le proprie passioni
all'estero
mi devo confessare che anch'io quando ho
creato la prima startup Sono emigrato
all'estero proprio perché non pensavo
che in Italia ci potesse essere il
terreno fertile per realizzare i miei
sogni
Ma poi
poi sono tornato i sette anni fa ho
creato una startup innovativa per
l'analisi automatica dei processi e la
startup ha funzionato talmente bene che
è stata acquisita dalla multinazionali
BIEMME pensate siamo stati la seconda
società italiana di prodotto software
acquisita in tutta la storia di IBM
il prodotto
aveva come obiettivo la capacità di
analizzare automaticamente i processi
delle nostre aziende partendo dai dati
Quindi come una macchina raggi x
tipicamente noi ci creiamo delle
aspettative sul funzionamento dei nostri
processi delle aziende e poi ci rendiamo
conto che la realtà a volte è molto
diversa Ecco la soluzione fa proprio
questo in automatico riesce a
rappresentarti la realtà dei tuoi
processi e fa anche un po' di più ha un
sofisticato software di simulazione che
consente di definire Quali sono i
cambiamenti che vuoi apportare la tua
azienda e come una macchina del tempo ti
porta nel futuro per vedere quali
saranno gli effetti di questi
cambiamenti
il tutto Seduto nella tua comoda
scrivania senza cambiare niente
una volta avuto questa brillante idea
abbiamo dovuto mettere a terra e quindi
abbiamo dovuto creare una startup
innovativa che fosse anche sostenibile
partendo dall'Italia
e per farlo abbiamo studiato il modello
della Silicon Valley Silicon Valley
ecosistema quasi perfetto Ci sono le
migliori università berkeley e Stanford
che sfornano ogni giorno invenzioni e
Talenti ci sono una miriade di startup
che crescono Grazie a questo anche
trainate dai colossi quali Microsoft
quali Apple quali Tesla quali Oracle
e poi ci sono gli investitori i venture
capitalist che raccolgono fondi privati
e pubblici per accelerare la crescita di
queste startup perché sanno che una su
10 porterà risultati impressionanti Ecco
partendo da questo abbiamo cercato di
calare nel contesto italiano quella che
abbiamo chiamato la Virtual Silicon
Valley Perché di certo non potevamo
pensare di trovare in Italia Tutto
quello che un ecosistema quasi perfetto
può fornire
Ma le idee ce le avevamo
i talenti per guidare questo progetto in
parte abbiamo cercato in Europa le
università che ci potessero supportare
in questo ambito e abbiamo trovato
l'università di Eindhoven con il
professor
e l'università di Padova con il
professor Massimiliano De leoni con
decenni di esperienza nell'analisi
automatica dei processi proprio quello
che serviva a noi a questo punto
servivano risorse eccezionali nella
squadra e abbiamo trovato il nostro
direttore tecnico in Romania un genio
dell'informatica e dopo di che abbiamo
creato un team di risorse che ho la
grande fortuna di avere guidato tra
l'Italia e Malta e dopo due anni siamo
riusciti a uscire con la prima versione
del prodotto e a posizionarla sul
mercato
in quel in quel periodo abbiamo dovuto
ahimè sperimentare anche la resilienza
della nostra startup perché ci siamo
imbattuti anche nella pandemia e devo
dire che grazie a questo modello che per
esigenze necessità è slegato dai vincoli
geografici siamo riusciti a reggere
molto bene anche questo impatto
un anno dopo siamo stati nominati col
vendor da parte di Gardner Garner lo
possiamo vedere come la guida Michelin
dei prodotti software essere nominato
curvendor identifica la tua società in
un determinato ambito come quella col
più alto tasso di innovazione
è un po' Come prendere una stella
Michelin per un ristorante
L'anno dopo siamo passati da da
cuvendolo OT vendor cioè una guida
Michelin della Silicon Valley ci ha
nominato ad vendor e ci ha chiamato
quindi dall'Italia alla Silicon Valley
per ricevere il premio la nomina appunto
di Hot vendo Sempre nell'ambito del
nostro prodotto per l'analisi dei
processi
questa stella Michelin ti aiuta ti aiuta
come italiano perché ti dà tanta
credibilità ti apre tante porte ti dà
grande visibilità ci ha consentito di
acquisire clienti importanti anche
all'estero anche negli Stati Uniti e di
essere diciamo invitati a tutta una
serie di eventi dove abbiamo incontrato
una serie di multinazionali tra le quali
IBM quando ci siamo incontrati è stato
amore a prima vista
adesso il momento di di porci una
qualche domanda La prima è ma ne vale la
pena di creare start up innovative
nell'ambito dei prodotti software in
Italia Beh quello che vi posso dire che
giocare nella serie A dei prodotti
software non è poi così male
accettare ogni giorno le sfide di
competitor europei e statunitensi e a
volte perde le volte vincerle è
un'esperienza bellissima
il secondo punto è che Le startup
innovative nell'ambito dei prodotti
software possono creare grande valore
valore che poi si può decidere come
reinvestire pensate che una startup
innovativa neanche dei prodotti sotto
riceve una valutazione che va da 10
volte a 30 volte il suo fatturato
ricorrente
la seconda domanda che che ci potremmo
fare è ma era veramente necessario
vendere IBM non ci potevano essere
soluzioni alternative Beh avremmo potuto
cercare capitali di rischio Quindi
cercare appunto questi famosi venture
capitalist e ci avrebbero consentito di
crescere e magari addirittura di
diventare uno Unicorn
uno Unicorn è una startup innovativa che
riceve dagli analisti una valutazione
superiore al miliardo di dollari
Sì non è proprio facile come obiettivo e
per darvi un'idea di come stanno andando
questi unicorni in Europa Voglio
condividere con voi un grafico una
statistica relativa al 2022 dei
principali unioni con per
nazione nell'ambito europeo come potete
vedere UK la fa da padrone
seguita in grande spolvero dalla
Germania e dalla Francia l'Italia
Purtroppo il fanalino di coda con uno
unicorc in questo caso è satispay quindi
quell'app per gestire pagamenti
automatici nell'ambito dei prodotti
servizi e cosa dire emerge chiaramente
che ci sono nazioni con un mindset
adatto a supportare la crescita lo
sviluppo di questi Unicorn e altre
purtroppo ancora no
Ma noi ci dobbiamo credere e mi il
messaggio che vi voglio dare è proprio
questo
dobbiamo mettere a frutto le nostre
passioni qui in Italia dobbiamo mettere
i nostri Talenti al servizio della
nazione più bella del mondo
per creare start up start up innovative
che possono in futuro diventare anche
degli Unicorn
Noi siamo già partiti e abbiamo creato
una startup nell'ambito della cucina
questa volta un robot che cucina per voi
un Master Chef al nostro servizio
una soluzione che unirà l'eccellenza dei
distretti industriali Emiliani quali
l'artificiali intelligence la robotica
l'elettronica e la cultura per la cucina
il Food
democratizzeremo la buona cucina
italiana nel mondo così finalmente
gli americani non mangeranno più la
pastasciutta scotta
[Applauso]